hey David I'm curious have you ever
asked to speak to the manager are you
one of those guys barely ever there are
very very few circumstances where I have
had to lobby a sort of complaint of some
kind and when I do I am really really
really polite partially because it's
happening more and more that like I'll
go to a restaurant and then when I'm
leaving the restaurant someone will come
up to me and say hey didn't want to
bother you while you were eating but
loved the show and it would be so
embarrassing if I threw a fit to a
manager at a restaurant and a viewer
sighed and was horrified by it but in
all seriousness when I've had to lobby a
complaint it's most often been either
dealing with Airlines or dealing with
hotels those are the most common times
that something was truly wrong you know
a shower that leaked all over the
bathroom floor ok well that that's got
to be dealt with
you know I these are relatively limited
incidents but when something like that
happens I am always very polite to
people who are working often underpaid
in a variety of different jobs and one
of the most cringe inducing things for
me socially is when I go out it happens
most frequently at restaurants I go to
restaurants with people usually that I
don't know that well because I like to
think I don't closely associate with
people who treat waitstaff poorly and
someone starts being rude to the
waitstaff it is a an immediate red flag
if that's how you're treating in front
of people you barely know in public this
is how you're treating people who are
underpaid working in what are often not
the best environments depending on where
it is that they work and you're treating
them like like that you're not someone I
want to be friends with you're not
someone I want to do business with
you're not someone I really want to be
spending time with so I do sometimes ask
to speak to the manager and I'm always
extremely polite when I do it and I
think of the last time I had to do
something like it was just a bad hotel I
think it was where was I I think it was
when I was last in Montreal a few months
ago there was the
plumbing stopped working multiple times
at the hotel and eventually I asked them
it wasn't like a room issue I said you
know I need to be able to get in the
shower and and flush the toilet I'm
gonna need you to transfer us to a
different hotel and sort of like take
care of the arrangements and they did
and that was it and they apologized and
nobody nobody was embarrassed or shamed
by me I just said this is what we got to
do please treat everybody with kindness
and respect that's my that's my sign-off
today if you have a question you want
answered let me know ideally via email
that's the most sort of personal and
professional way to let me know that you
have a question you want answered use
the contact us page at david pakman.com
great bonus show for you today coming up
next if you are a member or a patron
otherwise I will talk to you on Monday